وسط الحضاره والضجيج يقف هذا البيت في رام
الله شاهدا على ثقافه وتراثي من سكنوه قبل
اكثر من 150 عاما
البيت من الخارج حافظ على شكله قدر
المستطاع لكنه من الداخل تحول الى دكان
هدايا من نوع خاص
[موسيقى]
هذا مجال انا طول عمري بحبه حتى في بيتي
دائما بجمع اشغال يدويه انا بطرش بايدي
بجمع قش بجمع بكون عندي خزف هذا مجال انا
بعشقه يعني انه عشان هيك قررنا انه هذا
اثبت اثبت مشروع يليق بالقدم وبتراثنا
ويتلاءم مع البيت نفسه يعني كل ما في
المكان يروي حكايه الفلسطيني قبل 100
واكثر وبعضه يروي تاريخ المكان وصفات
السكان لذلك سمي هذا البيت ارث
[موسيقى]
سميناه لانه هو بيت موروث من جيل لجيل عبر
اجيال والقطع الموجوده في الفكره منها
انها قطعه الست تشتريها لبنتها وبنتها
تورثها لبنت بنتها فهي قطع الها قيمه
جماليه وتراثيه عاليه عدا عن قيمتها
الماديه فهو الفكره منه هذا قردنا
الفلسطيني من بيت لقطعه لكل شيء موجود فيه
رمي ما هذا المكان قبل ان ياكله الزمان
وتهدمه الاشجار بجذورها وفروعها ليكتمل
المشهد الفلسطيني
بابسط صوره من الخارجي ومن الداخل
من بيت ارث في رام الله خالد القاسم
العربيه